la identificación de una nueva variante
del coronavirus ha encendido las alarmas
en todo el mundo y sudáfrica del país
donde se ha identificado inicialmente
esta nueva variante llamada omicron por
el número de mutaciones se que contiene
ha sido uno de los países más afectados
en conjunto con otros cinco países del
sur de áfrica
las restricciones han venido sobre todo
de países europeos pse que han iniciado
unas restricciones en el tráfico aéreo
de estos países del sur de áfrica y esto
significaría un fuerte impacto económico
a medida que empieza la temporada de
verano aquí en el hemisferio sur del
continente que se espera que trajera una
reactivación económica después de casi
dos años de pandemia lo que ha causado
uno ser muy fuertes impactos en la
economía de los de estos países y cuyas
restricciones se de seguir en pie y se
reflejarían en la pérdida de miles de
empleos el gobierno sudafricano también
ha calificado de prematuras estas duras
restricciones dado que aún se sabe muy
poco de esta variante que bien podría
ser más contagiosa e incluso ser
resistente a las vacunas el país ha
vivido un clima de ansiedad y de gran
frustración por estas medidas pero
también porque la población teme un
incremento radical en el número de
infectados incluso entre la población
vacunada y se teme también a que vengan
nuevos confinamientos e incluso el
endurecimiento del toque de queda
recordemos que sudáfrica no ha levantado
el toque de queda desde que inició la
pandemia en en marzo de 2020 la
comunidad científica en sudáfrica
también así como el gobierno han hecho
un llamado a los gobiernos europeos para
que reconsideren estas medidas en un
momento en el que aún es prematuro y
para que premien a sudáfrica más bien
por la capacidad de identificar estas
nuevas variantes gracias a su capacidad
científica en lugar de castigar y aislar
al país cuando más necesita el apoyo
internacional